Having talked about the storage resources
provided by the Beta ISA, let's design the
Beta instructions themselves.
This might be a good time to print a copy
of the handout called the "Summary of Beta
Instruction Formats" so you'll have it for
handy reference.
The Beta has three types of instructions:
compute instructions that perform arithmetic
and logic operations on register values, load
and store instructions that access values
in main memory, and branch instructions that
change the value of the program counter.
We'll discuss each class of instructions in
turn.
In the Beta ISA, all the instruction encodings
are the same size: each instruction is encoded
in 32 bits and hence occupies exactly one
32-bit word in main memory.
This instruction encoding leads to simpler
control-unit logic for decoding instructions.
And computing the next value of the program
counter is very simple:
for most instructions, the next instruction
can be found in the following memory location.
We just need to add 4 to the current value
of program counter to advance to the next
instruction.
As we saw in Part 1 of the course, fixed-length
encodings are often inefficient in the sense
that the same information content (in this
case, the encoded program) can be encoded
using fewer bits.
To do better we would need a variable-length
encoding for instructions, where frequently-occurring
instructions would use a shorter encoding.
But hardware to decode variable-length instructions
is complex since there may be several instructions
packed into one memory word, while other instructions
might require loading several memory words.
The details can be worked out, but there's
a performance and energy cost associated with
the more efficient encoding.
Nowadays, advances in memory technology have
made memory size less of an issue and the
focus is on the higher-performance needed
by today's applications.
Our choice of a fixed-length encoding leads
to larger code size, but keeps the hardware
execution engine small and fast.
The computation performed by the Beta datapath
happens in the arithmetic-and-logic unit (ALU).
We'll be using the ALU designed in Part 1
of the course.
The Beta ALU instructions have 4 instruction
fields.
There's a 6-bit field specifying the ALU operation
to be performed - this field is called the
opcode.
The two source operands come from registers
whose numbers are specified by the 5-bit "ra"
and "rb" fields.
So we can specify any register from R0 to
R31 as a source operand.
The destination register is specified by the
5-bit "rc" field.
This instruction format uses 21 bits of the
32-bit word, the remaining bits are unused
and should be set to 0.
The diagram shows how the fields are positioned
in the 32-bit word.
The choice of position for each field is somewhat
arbitrary, but to keep the hardware simple,
when we can we'll want to use the same field
positions for similar fields in the other
instruction encodings.
For example, the opcode will always be found
in bits [31:26] of the instruction.
Here's the binary encoding of an ADD instruction.
The opcode for ADD is the 6-bit binary value
0b100000 - you can find the binary for each
opcode in the Opcode Table in the handout
mentioned before.
The "rc" field specifies that the result of
the ADD will be written into R3.
And the "ra" and "rb" fields specify that
the first and second source operands are R1
and R2 respectively.
So this instruction adds the 32-bit values
found in R1 and R2, writing the 32-bit sum
into R3.
Note that it's permissible to refer to a particular
register several times in the same instruction.
So, for example, we could specify R1 as the
register for both source operands AND also
as the destination register.
If we did, we'd be adding R1 to R1 and writing
the result back into R1, which would effectively
multiply the value in R1 by 2.
Since it's tedious and error-prone to transcribe
32-bit binary values, we'll often use hexadecimal
notation for the binary representation of
an instruction.
In this example, the hexadecimal notation
for the encoded instruction is 0x80611000.
However, it's *much* easier if we describe
the instructions using a functional notation,
e.g., "ADD(r1,r2,r3)".
Here we use a symbolic name for each operation,
called a mnemonic.
For this instruction the mnemonic is "ADD",
followed by a parenthesized list of operands,
in this case the two source operands (r1 and
r2), then the destination (r3).
So we'll understand that ADD(ra,rb,rc) is
shorthand for asking the Beta to compute the
sum of the values in registers ra and rb,
writing the result as the new value of register
rc.
Here's the list of the mnemonics for all the
operations supported by the Beta.
There is a detailed description of what each
instruction does in the Beta Documentation
handout.
Note that all these instructions use same
4-field template, differing only in the value
of the opcode field.
This first step was pretty straightforward
- we simply provided instruction encodings
for the basic operations provided by the ALU.
Now that we have our first group of instructions,
we can create a more concrete implementation
sketch.
Here we see our proposed datapath.
The 5-bit "ra" and "rb" fields from the instruction
are used to select which of the 32 registers
will be used for the two operands.
Note that register 31 isn't actually a read/write
register, it's just the 32-bit constant 0,
so that selecting R31 as an operand results
in using the value 0.
The 5-bit "rc" field from the instruction
selects which register will be written with
the result from the ALU.
Not shown is the hardware needed to translate
the instruction opcode to the appropriate
ALU function code - perhaps a 64-location
ROM could be used to perform the translation
by table lookup.
The program counter logic supports simple
sequential execution of instructions.
It's a 32-bit register whose value is updated
at the end of each instruction by adding 4
to its current value.
This means the next instruction will come
from the memory location following the one
that holds the current instruction.
In this diagram we see one of the benefits
of a RISC architecture:
there's not much logic needed to decode the
instruction to produce the signals needed
to control the datapath.
In fact, many of the instruction fields are
involves the steps shown here:
the instruction is
loaded from the memory
location whose address is
specified by the program
counter.
When the requested data
is returned by the memory,
the instruction
fields are converted
to the appropriate control
signals for the datapath,
selecting the source operands
from the specified registers,
directing the ALU to perform
the specified operation,
and storing the result in the
specified destination register.
The final step in
executing an instruction
is updating the
value of the program
counter to be the address
of the next instruction.
This execution loop is
performed again and again.
Modern machines can execute
up more than a billion
instructions per second!
The discussion so far
has been a bit abstract.
Now it’s time to roll up our
sleeves and figure out what
instructions we want
our system to support.
The specification of instruction
fields and their meaning
along with the details
of the datapath design
are collectively called the
instruction set architecture
(ISA) of the system.
The ISA is a detailed functional
specification of the operations
and storage
mechanisms and serves
as a contract
between the designers
of the digital hardware
and the programmers who
will write the programs.
Since the programs are stored
in main memory and can hence be
changed, we’ll
call them software,
to distinguish them from
the digital logic which,
once implemented,
doesn’t change.
It’s the combination of hardware
and software that determine
the behavior of our system.
The ISA is a new
layer of abstraction:
we can write programs
for the system
without knowing
the implementation
details of the hardware.
As hardware
technology improves we
can build faster systems without
having to change the software.
You can see here that over
a fifteen year timespan,
the hardware for executing
the Intel x86 instruction set
went from executing 300,000
instructions per second
to executing 5 billion
instructions per second.
Same software as before, we’ve
just taken advantage of smaller
and faster MOSFETs to build
more complex circuits and faster
execution engines.
But a word of
caution is in order!
It’s tempting to make choices
in the ISA that reflect
the constraints of current
technologies, e.g.,
the number of
internal registers,
the width of the operands,
or the maximum size of main
memory.
But it will be hard to change
the ISA when technology
improves since there’s a
powerful economic incentive
to ensure that old software
can run on new machines,
which means that a particular
ISA can live for decades
and span many generations
of technology.
If your ISA is successful,
you’ll have to live with any
bad choices you made
for a very long time.
Designing an ISA is hard!
What are the operations
that should be supported?
How many internal registers?
How much main memory?
Should we design the
instruction encoding
to minimize program size or to
keep the logic in the control
unit as simple as possible?
Looking into our
crystal ball, what
can we say about the computation
and storage capabilities
of future technologies?
We’ll answer these questions by
taking a quantitative approach.
First we’ll choose a set
of benchmark programs,
chosen as representative of
the many types of programs we
expect to run on our system.
So some of benchmark
programs will
perform scientific and
engineering computations,
some will manipulate
large data sets
or perform database
operations, some
will require specialized
computations for graphics
or communications, and so on.
Happily, after many
decades of computer use,
several standardized
benchmark suites
are available for us to use.
We’ll then implement the
benchmark programs using
our instruction set and simulate
their execution on our proposed
datapath.
We’ll evaluate the results to
measure how well the system
performs.
But what do we mean by “well”?
That’s where it
gets interesting:
“well” could refer to execution
speed, energy consumption,
circuit size, system cost, etc.
If you’re designing
a smart watch,
you’ll make different choices
than if you’re designing
a high-performance graphics
card or a data-center server.
Whatever metric you choose to
evaluate your proposed system,
there’s an important design
principle we can follow:
identify the common
operations and focus on them
as you optimize your design.
For example, in
general-purpose computing,
almost all programs
spend a lot of their time
on simple arithmetic
operations and accessing values
in main memory.
So those operations
should be made as fast
and energy efficient
as possible.
Now, let’s get to work designing
our own instruction set
and execution engine, a
system we’ll call the Beta.